throw to have him back here six years in
the US Army accepted into the Green
Berets the University of Texas let him
go back and forth to serve our country
as well as long snap for the program
where is an academic all-american the
Seattle Seahawks welcomed into their
camp in 2015 when he co-founded the
emerging vets and players organization
with Jay Glazer good to see you Nate
Boyer it's good to see you how are you
brother I'm doing pretty good good
no come well I got a lot of complaints
but I'm not gonna share them ok well you
you out you would have the floor if you
wanted to
let's get just jump right into this
thing with what's going on in the
national football league and the
national anthem and how often do you
speak to Colin Kaepernick do you in
contact with him much no not currently
not currently and not not because there
was any you know bad blood or anything
like that just kind of different paths I
think but we spoke you know through the
2016-2017 season when he was still
playing and then even the you know the
following a little bit of the following
year I guess which was last season huh
but no not directly I've talked to you
know I'd spoken with Eric Reid's home
last year and and a lot of other players
in the lambing Malcolm Jenkins and Doug
Baldwin and some of these other guys
that are obviously Chris long is a
really good friend that if well what's
your conversations about with these guys
um well initially you know it was it was
when everybody was first of all there
was a lot more players protesting last
year there's a lot different but it's
been about you know that work done off
the field that's the most important
thing to me and and I've continued to
push for you know a lot of them to share
that stuff and it's it's a tricky place
to be because sometimes you know people
feel weird about I don't know want to
say like it can sound like boasting you
know in a sense of like look what I'm
doing charity wise or whatever but for
this situation it's really important to
share what you're doing you know what
programs you're involved with or
initiatives you've started off the field
if because there's so many people that
continue to say all these players do you
know I don't have to do it at that time
can't they protest on their own time
what do they do the rest of week I don't
see them doing anything in the offseason
we don't see them
testing him like why would they protest
in the offseason like what do you mean
they just I think a lot of them have
this idea a lot of people have to say
this false narrative that these players
are protesting the national anthem not
during the national anthem and they're
not doing anything else you know the
other 350 whatever days of the year well
I want to get into that a little bit
more in a second but just to flesh out
in a way your history with this how did
you get hooked up with Kaepernick cuz
you are the one who told him hey instead
of sitting how about kneeling correct
correct yeah you know this was so it
sips its September
late August early September 2016 it's
you know the middle of the election and
it's like Trump versus Clinton and you
know everyone's just we're already we've
already been slowly dividing over the
last decade it feels like but it was
just more and more and very intense at
that time and then Colin you know sits
on the bench for the third game in a row
and finally somebody I think I some
reporter asked him like what why you
Steve watch from the NFL Network no it's
just some up not just some reporter good
you know he's a good guy he's a really
good guy yeah he's on my team he's he's
the real deal right you know and and
Colin said I'm not gonna stand for a for
the flag of a country that oppresses
black people in people of color and of
course with everything going on already
that just was you know another match on
the gasoline and a huge uproar you know
it's like everyone immediately takes
their side
you know digs in and it's like it's like
red team versus blue team or whatever
you want to call it and I got reached
out to you by a few different
publications to write something you know
some pretty pretty big ones and they
wanted me to write an opinion piece and
I think what they kind of wanted or
expected was you know I'm gonna tell
Colin why he should stand or why he has
to stand or whatever and instead I agree
- agreed
finally to write something with the Army
Times which is a very small publication
that no offense the army times but not a
lot of people read it sure and the
reason I did is because they said you
can review any format you want
you know it's it's it's all you like
whatever you want we will you know we'll
push it and so I wrote this open letter
to call him it all I did was explain my
history personal history you know my
relationship to what those symbols stand
for and also I thought it was important
to kind of ask the question you know why
threw that letter and and help him not
help him but allow him the opportunity
to to not only just read about why I
feel that way but also sort of feel like
he can can answer you know answer back
and possibly have a time I don't work
together yeah I have a dialogue and so
and he reached out you know I wrote that
letter it got shared by a lot of
specially a lot of sports writers was
the reason that it that it got out I
mean because you're a a football player
kind of a long snappers are people too
as you know
right that's true okay and representing
Texas yeah and also what six tours of
duty correct did you have six I did go
overseas six times three three combat
tours but okay okay right ten years
total six put that all together and
obviously you're gonna be on the radar
screen of a lot of people and still are
obviously today so what what was what
was the conversation that you had that
caused him to just say okay I'm gonna
kneel now cuz that's what everybody that
whole conversation you hear it now it's
now boiled down to players are kneeling
on the flag right right it's now it
boiled down to something that is
completely under onst right in the most
nuanced conversation we may have as an
American populace who involving sports
so how did that work yeah so so we got
sharing around you know that night the
next day I'm I'm gonna go on NFL Network
and do my first interview about it I'm
pretty nervous about that I'm in the
green room and Collins publicist called
me and said he wants to sit down with
you tomorrow before the game and I was
like really Wow okay so I jumped in an
uber from LA to San Diego and the next
day and met him down there in the lobby
of the team hotel
like four hours before kickoff and Chip
Kelly was a coach at the time and he was
like you know please have this
conversation I think it's important and
and we sat down and Eric rejoined us and
we just talked about you know our our
shared experiences our different
experiences also you know he explained
in detail about why he was doing it for
anybody that doesn't know at this point
which it's crazy if you don't and you're
following this story but you know it was
police brutality
you know the criminal justice system and
its shortcomings and racial inequality
essentially and you know by the end of
the conversation it was up to a point
where you know he was very gracious
towards me and was thankful for you know
or shared with me how grateful he was
for my service and for time and you know
he had friends doing the same but also
and I wanted to share with him some
viewpoints of other people in the
veteran community and I and I showed
some messages that affected him quite a
bit you know and I could tell by the way
he reacted like it it it kind of opened
his minds and slowed him down a little
bit and he he asked me if there was
another way to demonstrate another way
that he could he said I'm not gonna
stand like I said to do that and until
things start to change or I feel like
stuffs in motion I'm not gonna change
that and he asked me if there was
another way and I suggested first and
foremost to do something alongside his
teammates I thought that was very
important because whether they agree
with you or not right we need to be
together on stuff we need to be more
unified as a country and I think that's
a good symbol and and that's when I you
know thought of of kneeling just because
it's more of a sign of reverence you
know we need kneel to pray propose to
our wives when a players hurt on the
field everyone takes a knee it's always
a pretty respectful gesture as far as I
know and he thought that was more
powerful than sitting and he agreed to
do that and that that night he did it
for the first time in the game and I
stood next to him on the field again you
were there no and then since then we've
we've gone back to like you said it's
just this focus on who's protesting and
what's their form of protest what's the
gesture not what's behind it Nate Boyer
here on the rich Eisen show
and in that regard before you move on to
emerging vets and players and vets and
players org you mentioned how it's
important for players to show what
they're doing in the community even if
they're running the risk of it being on
the other end of an accusation of being
self-serving right okay
Kenny Stills who is one of the only few
remaining players to be kneeling during
the national anthem right now in Miami
tweeted out photographs of him meeting
with veterans and hanging with veterans
this past week Marco Rubio the senator
from Florida retweeted it we're putting
it up on the on the television screen
here you know Marco Rubio said no NFL
player does more community service than
Kay stills of the Miami Dolphins you
don't have to agree with how or why he
has chosen to exercise the First
Amendment before every game to
acknowledge the hours he gives
voluntarily on his day off to serve his
fellow Americans and then on the same
take the the famed Quinnipiac college
put out a poll with a plus or minus
error of almost four percent showing
that from last November to this very day
that there has been a five-point change
in the way Americans view the kneeling
during the national anthem as a form of
protest it went from 47 percent
disapproved to 50 set 47% disapprove in
fit part me 52 percent disapprove and 42
percent approve to now being split down
the middle at 47 percent do you think
that there has been a change in the
country the way that this is being
viewed Nate boy yeah I do
in what I've experienced and obviously
I've been sort of a lightning rod for a
lot of this so a lot of the I've
received a lot of comments from people
on on both sides of this issue that have
been you know very negative and very you
know hurtful and just attacks and stuff
but more than that throughout these last
two years I've seen a lot of people and
I got a lot of messages from people that
have said you know I never thought about
it
from that perspective whether it's from
a conservative perspective or a liberal
perspective and now I'm listening more
and I'm trying to to understand more and
just be more open-minded because that's
something I continue to try to push
towards people and help them understand
like open-mindedness is not necessarily
synonymous with like liberal values and
patriotism isn't synonymous with
conservative values you shouldn't can be
both in my opinion and and I think yeah
I mean that's a really cool I haven't
seen that stat that's actually really
interesting and you know Marco Rubio is
obviously a conservative voice and for
him to to share that that's cool like we
need to see more of that you know and
yeah I definitely encourage that so
let's talk about merging vets and
players in organization you you you form
with glaze right Jay Glazer who's got a
huge heart man - I love that guy a huge
head - he does is just huge
yeah that's all he's a stout man
you should stop man yep I agree I don't
say anything anymore I'd love to see
look I'd love to see his workout regimen
and see how it dovetails with the with
Mark Wahlberg's we didn't get over 230
veteran players org tell people what
this is about and how they can get
involved yeah awesome mate so you know
it was it was spawned it's actually
three years ago
well almost three years ago yeah it was
after I you know I'd been cut from the
Hawks and I was trying to figure out
what I was gonna do next and I thought
about going back into the military and
and Jay and I were having these similar
conversations Jay with a lot of
professional athletes and me with with
more veterans about people are you know
people reach out all the time a lot of
them reach out to Jay about hey I'm done
playing you know I'm having trouble
finding a purpose and feeling that same
excitement about life as I had before in
veterans obviously you know feel that
way and I think we're very aware that of
that as a country what struggles with
transitions what next what next I mean
Tony Gonzalez came to MVP just last
month and he talked about I mean I think
17 years obviously probably the greatest
tight end that ever played the game and
you know he was at dinner with his wife
three months after he retired and he
just
broke down you know and she was like
what's wrong and he's like I will I'll
never be great again no matter what I do
I will never be that great again and
that it's like really scary veterans
feel that same way it's that being part
of a mission that's very important
something that's so much bigger than you
the camaraderie but also the the the
highs that you experience you know
especially being in combat I mean it's I
know it's it's frightening it's hard to
relate that to anything else but in you
know if you've been in that situation
and you survived it like those feelings
it's hard to replicate anything like
that and and there's just there's 22
veterans a day are taking their own
lives it's just it's it's a huge
epidemic in our country and without
organizations like MVP I mean the VA
does what it can sure no it's it's very
hamstrung in a lot of ways and there's
20 million veterans d-date go back to
World War two
in our country today we need groups like
this that bring all of us back together
you know and and the thing about
athletes and in combat vets granted what
we did on the field battlefield football
field whatever it's so different but the
transition is very similar that locker
room is identical I'll tell you that and
you know just that that camaraderie
needing that connection again to what
you did before but also you know pushing
that forward and finding the next
challenge and you know just being a
warrior moving for with your life that's
why you Nate Boyer and Jay Glazer form
this and you go to vets and players org
find out if there's one in your area
correct I mean so the folk there's focus
groups there's ways to get together
there's what job summits and things
everything I mean right so we're right
now we're in Los Angeles Vegas and we
just opened in Chicago and because the
you know the NFL is on board now which
is huge so we've got you know the the
NFL you know the alumni associations and
the player engagement that have made
donations we've had you know Mike
McCarthy foundation cut us a big check
the Falcons are on board now like we are
growing and we're gonna be everywhere
every NFL city's the goal and we'll be
there within a few years fantastic it is
fantastic that's great and you're going
to Austin this weekend I am there's a
pretty big market in USC yeah it's a
couple teams that are sure
to find themselves again to talk about
the struggle with the transition we'll
get there but yeah it's still it's a
great rivalry obviously and yeah I'll be
in Austin the greatest city in America
were you I'm just trying to figure out
your history were you overseas during
the USC Texas big game I was actually on
I was actually in training I was not
overseas but I was in training I was out
in the field and they led us they gave
us a break for that game and we watched
it like the the squad I was on it was I
was probably 20-something of us at the
time watched it on this little 19 inch
TV and I'm you know I grew up in the bay
area of California guy had never lived
in Texas I pulled for USC sure would you
run a longhorn yeah and a Texas buddy of
mine he goes to bed at the end of the
you know the third quarter or whatever
when they were down a couple scores
because he was like I it's over I he
just quit and I said I woke him up in
the morning I'm letting you know Texas
won right and he's like no I'm like yeah
so that was the beginning of my love
affair with the Longhorns
but the Longhorns well but they broke
your heart first it's what you're saying
in a way I mean they did I mean I wasn't
a USC fans okay I just was pulling for
them for regional reasons okay and now
here you are you're going there so
anybody who else Makana he'll be there
I'm sure right yeah yeah of course he's
gonna he'll be he's hitting me up like
crazy I see I'm just kidding guys
together yeah this week is a good dude
he's a die-hard logger you a hipster
each other
he's our the jacket you ready uniform
he's like why is this guy standing so
close to me I do look a lot bigger than
him there though yeah looking that's
that's that's Dallas buyers club he was
losing weight I see what you're saying
good to see you Nate you too come back
anytime of course we're 37 to follow
mates exploits on Twitter thanks vets
and players org is how you can get
involved with merging vets and players
which a great organization the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience